[Musique]
en direct de l'Université des baies de
l'Ouest parisien avec Nicolas dandry
bonjour bonjour Patrice nous recevons
pierre Bellier bonjour président du
bonjour départemental des Yvelines vous
êtes fidèle cette université des mers
parce que tout simplement nous sommes en
couple les mères et le département c'est
le couple qui comme l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure notre ami président du Sénat
Gérard Larcher c'est le couple qui a
fondé la République et qui aujourd'hui
la fait tourner largement largement et
puis c'est une fonction que vous avez
exercé la fonction de mai je crois que
c'est une fonction que vous avez adoré
aussi ça je vous le confirme c'est le
plus beau métier du monde alors
justement vous parliez de ces relations
entre le Conseil départemental et les
mairies sur quel dans quel domaine vous
travaillez plus précisément ensemble
tous les projets d'investissement des
communes qu'il s'agisse d'un terrain de
sport qu'il s'agisse d'une école qu'il
s'agisse de la réfection des routes
communales toute la vie quotidienne
a besoin d'investissement et le
département des Yvelines et un gros
investisseur aux côtés des communes nous
les subventionnons nous pouvons parfois
aller jusqu'à 70% de subventions
c'est-à-dire le maximum prévu par la loi
et non seulement nous les accompagnons
financièrement mais nous les
accompagnons aussi dans ce qu'on appelle
l'ingénierie c'est-à-dire la capacité à
réaliser les projets sur les 259
communes des Yvelines presque enfin
entre 15200 ont des services techniques
limités par la faiblesse de leur budget
et donc le département mais
à leur disposition une agence
d'ingénierie qui s'appelle d'ailleurs
engenery pour à la fois préparer leur
dossier de demande de subvention mais
aussi pour ensuite accompagner toute la
phase de réalisation des travaux c'est
vous comblez ou vous complétez un les
moyens de l'État finalement à travers
cette action que vous faites en faveur
des communes la réalité Nicolas c'est
que nous remplaceons
l'état faisait ça auparavant lorsqu'il y
avait des directions départementales de
l'équipement c'était les directions
départementales de l'équipement qui
remplissaient cette fonction et c'est
vrai que l'idée m'est venue en voyant au
moment où l'État s'est restructuré il y
a maintenant une douzaine d'années et à
supprimer des grands services comme
celui de l'aide aux mers dans les
directions départementales de
l'équipement c'est ainsi que il y a 12
ans mais venu l'idée de créer cette
agence alors quand on discute avec les
maires qui sont ici ils disent qu'ils
ont un vrai problème de financement
c'est à dire qu'il y a moins de recettes
et des dépenses qui s'accélèrent je
pense que c'est la même chose au niveau
du conseil départemental notamment sur
le rôle social de du conseil
départemental
quelle solution on peut trouver à ça
c'est toujours facile effectivement
d'évoquer les problèmes moins évidents
de trouver des solutions moi ce qui
meurt le plus et ce sur quoi je pense il
va falloir qu'on revienne et rapidement
c'est qu'il n'y a maintenant plus de
liens fiscal entre des habitants et un
territoire ou plus exactement ce lien
fiscal devient de plus en plus ténu et
donc nous avons des concitoyens qui nous
en demandent toujours plus parce qu'il
n'imagine pas ce que ça coûte parce que
ça n'a pas vraiment de conséquence
financière pour eux la dernière
conséquence financière pour nos
concitoyens ce sont ceux qui acquittent
la taxe foncière donc les propriétaires
mais toutes
les communes n'ont pas une majorité de
propriétaires ou 100% de propriétaire
donc un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens sont toujours plus exigeants
sans en mesurer les conséquences et ça
il faut recréer ce lien alors ensuite il
faut très probablement essayer de
rationaliser un peu la
c'est vrai pour les communes les
intercals les départements mais c'est
d'abord la création de ce lien de ce
vrai lien la recréation pardon qui peut
calmer cette cette espèce de de
spirale de la dépense par exemple la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation oui
alors la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation c'est pas très populaire ce
que je veux dire c'est une bêtise parce
qu'au moins on savait qu'on payait
quelque chose à la commune quand demain
ma mère va devoir arbitrer entre
maintenir la température de la piscine à
28 degrés ou la mettre à 25 degrés parce
que il a besoin de faire ses trois
degrés d'économie ceux qui payent
l'impôt vont être d'accord mais ceux qui
le payent pas ne seront pas d'accord et
si ceux qui ne payent pas l'impôt sur
majoritaire dans la commune le maire
sera battu aux élections et si les
battus aux élections sont successeurs
s'empresse sera de faire tout l'inverse
donc c'est très très dangereux
finalement ce que ce dont vous parlez
c'est un principe institutionnel ça
s'appelle l'autonomie financière des
collectivités territoriales et je les
dis c'est un principe constitutionnel
c'est la norme supérieure dans le schéma
politique français comment on peut
atteindre aujourd'hui à ce principe
constitutionnel sans que les élus locaux
finalement ne fassent pas un recours
parce que vous pouvez vous avez ce droit
de faire un recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel que ça a été tranché par
le Conseil constitutionnel qui a laissé
passer à toutes les réformes qui ont
amené à cette disparition ou cette quasi
disparition du lien fiscal dans les
Yvelines enfin dans les départements
pardon ça n'est donc pas que dans les
Yvelines le lien a quasiment totalement
disparu puisque c'est un lien très
indirect à travers les droits de
mutation ce qu'on appelle les droits
notariaux mais nous n'avons plus
d'impôts directs il y a pas de partie de
taxe d'habitation pas de pas de partie
de taxe foncières donc et cette
disparition du lien elle a été validée
par le Conseil constitutionnel mais
l'état qu'on pense quand même que je
vous le dites il y a aussi un transfert
notamment des recettes de la TVA
aujourd'hui vers les départements oui
mais la compensation d'État n'empêche
d'abord on pourra beaucoup discuter
puisqu'on voit bien sur les dépenses
sociales l'état nous dit on compense à
l'Europe les euros de l'État ne sont pas
les oraux des départements c'est pas les
mêmes
donc il y a la valeur de l'euro pour
l'État c'est 0,70% de la valeur de
l'euro pour le département 30% ne nous
est pas toujours pensé mais je ferme
cette parenthèse donc fondamentalement
c'est pas les compensations je vais même
pas critiquer ça c'est l'absence de lien
je suis citoyen dans ma commune mais je
paie pas d'impôts la réalité on le sait
c'est que je ne suis pas un citoyen à
part entière parce que je ne suis pas
responsabilisé dans la dépense de ma
commune c'est vrai qu'il y a un lien
historique entre l'impôt et la
démocratie et on doit parler avec le
président du Sénat général marché tout à
l'heure il est favorable à un nouveau
pas vers la décentralisation un nouveau
étape de décentralisation je crois que
c'est de favorable aussi c'est vrai
qu'il faudrait arriver à avoir une
autonomie une plus grande autonomie des
collectivités territoriales il faut un
état qui pose les règles nous en avons
besoin c'est le principe de l'unité
nationale et de notre destin commun mais
ensuite un état qui dans son action
quotidienne se limite aux grandes
missions régaliennes assurer la sécurité
à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur des
frontières la représentation de la
France
assuré la cohérence des programmes
d'éducation mais ensuite c'est vrai que
au quotidien Le Monde très complexe la
diversité des territoires quand on a
créé les territoires les départements
les communes la population était
harmonieusement répandue répandit pardon
sur le territoire en National
aujourd'hui il y a les métropoles il y a
le ce qu'on appelle la diagonale du vide
donc les territoires sont très
différents et c'est cette différence ce
qui justifie la décentralisation et non
pas la déconcentration parce que quand
on nous parle aujourd'hui de déc
réalisation on confond souvent du côté
de l'État avec la déconcentration c'est
pas de fonctionnaire d'État dont on a
besoin c'est d'élus responsable devant
les électeurs et pourtant vous au début
de cette entretien vous critiquez le
fait que certains services de l'État
disparaissent et pourtant ces services
de l'État accompagnés les communes c'est
pas un peu paradoxal finalement je ne
l'ai pas critiqué Nicolas ne vous
preniez pas que j'ai dit que ça
n'existait plus et je donne le droit
bien entendu l'état fait ce qu'il veut
c'est à nous après d'essayer de trouver
des des solutions alors ce qui
m'inquiète plus c'est quand l'État ne
fait plus tout en voulant faire semblant
encore de faire et dans ce cas là il
empêche et on va pas rentrer dans trop
dans le détail mais quand on voit en
particulier dans les Yvelines comment
l'État peut à la fois exiger des
communes de construire et d'autres
services de l'État y compris des
services qui devraient être aidants
empêche de construire il y a un moment
il faut être cohérent et c'est pour ça
qu'il vaut mieux transférer plus de
pouvoir aux élus locaux qui eux sont
plus dans une situation de cohérence
parce que il voit mieux tous les aspects
d'un problème et donc ils peuvent
trancher mais qui transfert de
compétences dit forcément transfert
aussi de moyens
c'est bien pourquoi tout à l'heure la
nécessité de recréer une fiscalité
locale dans lequel les citoyens payent
et pas simplement une fiscalité
additionnelle de celle de l'État on a eu
l'impression justement au moment de la
crise de
sanitaire de la covid qui est une prise
de conscience justement que les
collectivités territoriales savaient
faire ce que l’étonne savait pas faire
pour ça qu'on en a pas tiré peut-être
encore toutes les conséquences et qu'il
faudrait les tirer
oui c'est totalement regrettable parce
que si une crise
sanitaire se reproduisait en France je
crains que nous n'ayons tiré pas grand
enseignement de celle que nous avons
traversé et en particulier
dans le secteur sanitaire je revendique
la décentralisation pas en totalité mais
d'une bonne partie de la santé il y a un
secteur qui est complètement sinistré
c'est le secteur de la médecine scolaire
la médecine scolaire est là remplie une
mission historique extraordinaire
puisqu'elle a éradiqué certaines
maladies quand
j'étais enfant il y a un certain temps
enfin c'était aussi avec le dernier je
précise bien qu'on est au 21e et que
c'était donc
j'étais pas là
on est éradiqué la tuberculose par
exemple la poliomyélite il y avait la
médecine scolaire était vraiment très
importante
je revendique le transfert de la
médecine scolaire au département avec
les dotations qui vont avec c'est à dire
celle qui existe aujourd'hui normalement
théoriquement et après on fera l'affaire
on se débrouillera nous avons déjà une
partie de cette compétence médecine à
travers la Protection Maternelle
Infantile les PMI pourquoi on ne va pas
un peu plus loin nous sommes nous dans
le département des Yvelines des
investisseurs dans du matériel médical
pourquoi nous ne sommes pas
administrateurs des groupes publics
hospitaliers on a même pas un strapanter
au conseil d'administration c'est tout
cela qu'il faut remettre en cause nous
ne sommes pas simplement les supplétifs
de l'État nous sommes des entrepreneurs
de services publics locaux alors nous
sommes ici à l'université de maire de
l'Ouest parisien ouest parisien sont les
Yvelines et les Hauts-de-Seine il y a eu
quand Patrick devager était président de
du département des Hauts-de-Seine un
projet de fusion entre les départements
où est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y a des de beaucoup
d'actions communes mais est-ce qu'on va
est-ce que vous êtes toujours favorable
à cette fusion
nous oui l'état non donc ça règle le
problème puisque c'était à lui de donner
l'autorisation ou pas donc aujourd'hui
nous avons entamé des collaborations
très étroites et qui sont un succès
incroyable je pense en particulier à
l'entretien du réseau routier mais il y
a bien d'autres exemples on va évoquer
tout à l'heure l'entreprise commune que
nous avons citalios qui est au service
des mers aménageurs donc nous maintenant
le cap c'est à dire nous essayons à la
fois de maintenir ce que nous avons
mutualisé et d'imaginer d'autres
mutualisations possibles dans un souci
d'économie et d'efficacité car je crois
que la dépense publique en France peut
être plus économique et plus efficace
alors vous parlez d'un souci
d'efficacité mais ce dossier de fusion
c'était aussi pour contrer le projet de
la métropole en tout cas la volonté de
faire peut-être disparaître les
départements vous étiez mobilisés avec
l'ensemble des départements de la grande
couronne de l'Île-de-France
aujourd'hui ça en est où justement ce
projet de fusion face à la au projet
métropolitain et on sait quand vous avez
un modèle assez particulier vous êtes en
faveur d'une certaine d'un certain
modèle de la métropole
alors je ne sais pas répondre à la
question Nicolas puisque ça n'est pas
nous qui avons pris l'initiative mais
sur le modèle vous mais si on nous
demandait de prendre l'initiative je
suis pour une métropole régionale
c'est-à-dire une métropole qui englobe
la totalité des sept départements de la
petite de la grande couronne autour de
Paris Paris inclus que cette métropole
est des pouvoirs métropolitains
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui touche au
transport et au développement économique
mais qu'elle puisse déléguer ensuite au
département lorsque c'est nécessaire
parce que je crois que le pilier de
cette métropole enfin les piliers plus
exactement doivent être les départements
nous avons une chance en Île-de-France
nous sommes le seul territoire de France
où tous les départements ont à peu près
la même population et donc le même
budget
2 millions d'habitants à Paris un peu
moins de 2 millions le plus peuplé après
c'est les Hauts-de-Seine avec un million
5 et on tourne tous entre un million 4
et 1 million cinq donc on pourrait avoir
une métropole rayonnante avec des
transferts massifs de l'État j'ai
toujours pas compris pourquoi le
président directeur général de la Régie
autonome des transports parisiens la
RATP est nommé en Conseil des ministres
c'est à la métropole régionale de
choisir qui doit diriger son opérateur
de transport public donc des transferts
de l'État à la métropole une métropole
qui elle s'organise pour pouvoir avec
les départements par le principe de
subsidiarité leur confier des missions
dans le domaine des transports dans le
domaine de l'économie les départements
concernant par ailleurs leur
responsabilité et la région
Île-de-France en tant que région et
elles deviennent donc métropole régional
mais avec un pouvoir métropolitain et
avec une élection
démocratique de la métropole alors on va
par définition sauf
la Russie les élections sont démocrates
c'était dans votre modèle vous disiez
que les conseillers départements élus
dans les conseils départementaux de la
région siègerait au Conseil
métropolitain vous avez un système dont
personne ne sait rien ne contexte pardon
la
démocratie le caractère démocratique
c'est l'élection des conseils municipaux
et des conseils communautaires comment
ça se passe sur la liste municipale il y
a des élus qui sont fléchés pour siéger
au conseil communautaire c'est ce qu'on
appelle une élection indirecte mais
c'est une élection on peut faire la même
chose à partir des départements il y
avait une très bonne idée qui était
l'élection de conseiller territoriaux
c'est-à-dire à la fois conseiller
départementaux et conseiller régionaux
le problème c'est canine de France ça
fera une assemblée métropolitaine de
plus de 500 personnes je pense que ça
serait déraisonnable en tout cas il y a
une nécessité de simplification et de
rapprochement voilà des pouvoirs des
citoyens merci infiniment bien merci
Patrice merci Nicolas et à l'année
prochaine j'espère oui
[Musique]